your art art that you've painted and
created in this movie James the just as
a back note your character is this very
successful sort of tech guru you've got
a lot of money you've got these very
cool inspired paintings all over the
place and you did them I did a lot of
them yes there was supposed to be a lot
of art in the in the house and they
showed me you know they consulted me
what kind of art do you think you would
have and they were it showed me kind of
very gerrant generic painting so I
thought well I have some paintings that
maybe would be funnier and would be more
in line with the with the character yeah
we I don't know if you're allowed to
show them well let's just show this one
I don't think we're allowed to show it
but I must have that who wouldn't want
that
yeah exactly so you painted that I hope
the title is something other than
humping capybaras yeah you know if it's
like on Wii number six yeah I got it
wrong I thought it was I thought they
were hamsters and so it was f-word
hamsters and then I put it online and
everyone's like no those are those are
capybara so I peed it up and you're an
artist who's willing to compromise and
then you get James isn't this right you
gave you gave Brian a a painting as a
gift yeah and what was it it was a
beautiful painting of a marijuana leaf I
think we have it I think we have this
painting there is a nice and I brought
it home to my wife we've been together
for almost 30 years and we have a nice
little Connecticut home and I said honey
where do you think this would fit and
she said I don't know if it would fit
anywhere over the bed over the bed he
actually painted it with the real
marijuana leaf in the painting
and so that's why
so it got held up at customs the drug
dogs are
[Laughter]
you